como el mecanismo s en eeuu no involucra
la formación de un kart vocación es
posible que ocurra el re arreglo o
también conocido como transposición
entonces veamos esta reacción sn uno del
lado izquierdo tenemos nuestro alumno de
alquilo o también llamado halogenuro de
alquilo nuestro solvente es el etanol y
del lado derecho tenemos el producto
ahora el primer paso es la pérdida del
grupo saliente entonces estos electrones
se van junto con el yodo para formar el
año en yoduro y con eso le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color rojo con
lo que el carbono rojo tendrá una carga
formal positiva vamos a dibujarlo
formamos un kart vocación y el carbono
de color rojo corresponde a este carbono
entonces este carbono tiene una carga
formal positiva y si observamos este
kart vocación podemos ver que es un kart
vocación secundario porque el carbono
rojo está unido directo
a otros 2 carbonos por eso este es un
kart vocación secundario y si se
acuerdan del vídeo sobre carbó cationes
y re arreglos aquí puede ocurrir un re
arreglo para formar un kart vocación más
estable y un cambio de metilo tiene
sentido entonces este grupo metilo se
cambiara a este carbono dibujemos lo que
ocurre ahora tenemos un grupo metilo por
aquí y el carbono de color rojo
corresponde a este carbono y como le
quitamos un enlace al carbono que estoy
circulando de color verde
entonces el carbono que es circulado de
verde corresponde a este carbono y ahora
ese es el carbono que tiene una carga
formal positiva entonces este es nuestro
carbó catión y qué tipo de carbó
cationes bueno si analizamos el carbono
que es circulado de verde podemos ver
que está unido directamente a 1 2 3
carbonos así que es un carbó catión
terciario es más estable que un carbó
catión secundario así que en este caso
al cambiar el grupo metilo incrementamos
la estabilidad es decir pasamos de un
carbó catión secundario a uno terciario
este es nuestro electro filo y ahora es
tiempo de que aparezca el núcleo filo
para atacar al electro filo en este caso
el núcleo filo es nuestro solvente
etanol así que esta es una reacción de
sol policies entonces si dibujamos una
molécula de etanol por aquí
y le ponemos su par de electrones libres
al oxígeno
uno de estos pares formará un enlace con
el carbono que circule de color verde
entonces el núcleo fy lo ataca al
electro filo y así formamos un enlace
entre el oxígeno y el carbono
entonces si dibujamos eso por aquí ahora
tenemos un enlace con este carbono y el
oxígeno aún está unido a un hidrógeno y
al estilo y supongamos que el par de
electrones libres que formaron el enlace
son estos electrones de color rosa
entonces esos electrones de color rosa
del oxígeno formaron este enlace y aún
tenemos un par de electrones libres en
el oxígeno ahí está y todo eso le da una
carga formal positiva al oxígeno
ahora si comparamos esto con el producto
final observen que lo último que tenemos
que hacer es simplemente desproteger
entonces el último paso del mecanismo es
la transferencia de un protón mediante
una reacción ácido base así que otra
molécula puede entrar y actuar como una
base entonces sí dibujamos el par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno
uno de estos electrones libres puede
tomar este protón y dejar estos
electrones en este oxígeno y así es como
finalmente obtenemos nuestro producto
que bueno lo podemos dibujar de
diferentes formas pero ese es nuestro
mecanismo sn uno con el real regla de un
kart vocaciòn veamos otro rearreglo de
un kart vocación en un mecanismo sn 1
pero esta vez empezaremos con este
alcohol en el ejemplo anterior el primer
paso fue la pérdida del grupo saliente
pero si ahora mostramos el movimiento de
los electrones hacia el oxígeno para
formar el ión hidróxido eso no
funcionará porque el ión hidróxido no es
un buen grupo saliente así que primero
necesitamos protón ar el alcohol para
tener un buen grupo saliente
entonces el primer paso de este
mecanismo es la transferencia de un
protón el alcohol funcionará como una
base y el h3 o más donar a un protón el
ión y tronío actuará como nuestro ácido
aquí tenemos h 3 o más y el alcohol
actuará como una base entonces un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno toman un
protón del hidrógeno nuestro primer paso
es la transferencia de un protón y eso
le da una carga formal positiva a este
oxígeno y aún tenemos un par de
electrones libres tenemos una carga
formal positiva en este oxígeno y
digamos que este par de electrones
libres tomaron este protón para formar
este enlace ahora sí ya estamos listos
para perder el grupo saliente porque
cuando estos electrones se vayan junto
con el oxígeno obtendremos agua y el
agua es un buen grupo saliente entonces
el primer paso es la transferencia del
protón
y el segundo paso es la pérdida del
grupo saliente y como le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color rojo ese
carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva la
dibujaré por aquí entonces el carbono de
color rojo corresponde a este carbono y
tenemos una carga formal positiva ahora
qué tipo de carbó cationes bueno el
carbono rojo está unido directamente a
otros dos carbonos así que este eso en
carbó catión secundario y podemos pensar
en la posibilidad de un real regla en el
vídeo sobre cationes y re arreglos otro
cambio que hicimos fue una transposición
de hidrógeno entonces miren en este
carbono de color rosa aún tenemos un
hidrógeno y un cambio o transposición de
ese hidrógeno nos dará un kart vocación
más estable entonces pensemos en este
hidrógeno y en estos dos electrones
cambiándose a este carbono de color rojo
dibujemos lo que nos queda este es el
carbono de color rojo entonces ya
teníamos un hidrógeno unido a este
carbono y con el cambio o transposición
del hidrógeno agregamos otro hidrógeno
en este carbono rojo así que ya no
tenemos una carga formal en este carbono
porque ahora la carga formal se pasó a
este carbono que estoy circulando de
verde perdió un enlace así que este
carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva y
qué tipo de carbó catión formamos bueno
el carbono verde está unido directamente
a 1 2 3 carbonos así que es un carbó
catión terciario la transposición de
hidrógeno nos dio un carbó catión más
estable y ahora que ya tenemos a nuestro
electro filo en el siguiente paso entra
el núcleo filo que en este caso es el
metanol voy a dibujar una molécula de
metanol por aquí tenemos el hidrógeno
y dos pares de electrones libres en el
oxígeno ok entonces el núcleo filo ataca
al electro filo así que a un par de
electrones libres en este oxígeno forman
un enlace con este carbono que es
circulado de color verde entonces vamos
a dibujar el resultado de ese ataque
núcleo físico hemos formado un enlace
entre el carbono de color verde y este
oxígeno ahí está y aún tenemos un grupo
metilo en este oxígeno y un hidrógeno
resaltemos los electrones ahora de color
azul estos electrones de color azul en
el oxígeno forman un enlace entre el
oxígeno y el carbono y aún tenemos un
par de electrones libres en este oxígeno
lo que le da una carga formal positiva y
también observen lo que hice con este
grupo estos 2 carbonos los dibujé hacia
abajo de esta forma porque existe una
rotación libre en este
así que lo podemos dibujar como queramos
yo lo dibujé así para que se parezca más
a nuestro producto
ahora si comparamos los dos últimos
pasos podemos ver que se da la
transferencia de un protón así que lo
único que nos falta por hacer es tomar
un protón y para eso tenemos un par de
opciones como base podemos usar ya sea
la molécula de agua que perdimos en este
paso o podemos usar otra molécula de
metanol no importa mucho que usemos yo
usaré la molécula de agua tanto el agua
como el metanol pueden actuar como una
base en el último paso de nuestro
mecanismo entonces en este caso el agua
toma este protón dejando estos
electrones y así es como se forma
nuestro producto final